[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you like that infamous word screamed by
Kirk Cousins last week after a huge road
win in New Orleans but we've got three
more important words for you chess not
checkers we see you Mike Vrabel well
played sir she's the queen and I'm the
rook and this is the Fiat betting show
presented by the Caesars Palace sports
book
my name is cabby Richards and she is our
betting insider Kelly the Queen Stuart
three more words heavy Road dogs this is
the week that the points matter the most
we'll get to that in just a moment
last week the Eagle suffered one more
huge injury they just couldn't overcome
which saw carson wentz knocked out of
the game versus seattle he went down and
so did my best bet but we're still 12 5
and 1 on the season and my divisional
round picks are coming right up let's go
cabbie let's do it the Vikings plus 7 at
the 49ers kicking off here soon total 44
and a half this one's going to be
awesome defense defense defense is gonna
be the name of the game this game will
be one in the trenches but I'm not so
sure about this Niners red zone defense
and all feel cold field advantage
doesn't matter as much in the playoffs
as people think
I like the under here but we're gonna
get to my best bet here at the end of
the show
Titans was 10 at the Ravens total 47 and
a half
this Titans team has been a force to
reckon with on the road this season
they've been making their backers money
all year long and this line isn't slated
to protect those teams remember we
talked about that last week when the
Saints game didn't get moved to nine or
nine and a half and stayed on that eight
it was really interesting this one's up
to ten because the books need to
mitigate some risk here
Ravens oh one of these best ATS teams
all season long I do like the Titans
here with too many points it is MVP
season it was very difficult to gameplan
for patch of mahomes so how on earth
will defensive coordinator Dean piece
for the Titans game plan for Lamar
Jackson my guess Madden 20 the Ravens
the Chiefs and the 49ers are all
considerable favorites this weekend and
Warren Sharpe office offers this
strategy to handicap they mean since
2013 in this round favorites of over
seven points home favorite took over
seven points all these guys obviously
off of the by their eight and one
straight up their four and five against
the spread and if you tease them by six
points you're going eight and one on
those teasers and that's a 89 percent
win rate and to beat a +6 juice the
teaser that is very plus TV that's a
great way to deal with these nine point
or more favorites is they're doing great
straight up but you're gonna need a
tease and to win against the screen
interesting now get there courtesy of
Warren sharp whose football insights are
excellent finding that sharp football on
Twitter shoutout to the left go podcast
Kelly what do you make of Warren Caesar
Laurens absolutely right home teams on a
six-point teaser over the last decade 21
in three during the divisional round of
the playoffs it's an absolutely
incredible stat he's right if you're
looking at T's either the Ravens and the
Chiefs
you probably have a winner in your
pocket
get over to Sunday start off at the noon
hour Texas +10 at the Chiefs total 51
and a half Shawn watt Watson and this
Texan team have proven they can win an
arrowhead
and what's been the narrative all weeks
they shouldn't have beaten the bills
well they did in overtime and they got
the w+ andy reid 22 and 3 against a
spread coming off a bye I have heard
that stat so many times this week and I
know it's tough to trust Bill O'Brien
but I do trust him here and a two mini
point situation I like the Texans +10
and for the big primetime game the
Seahawks plus for the Packers total of
45 I'm gonna be really honest with you
guys this has been one of the hardest
games for me to handicap so I'm gonna
break it down for you and then not play
the side whatsoever
Seattle over here as a dog covered ten
of their last 12 but they're old and
five against a spread at Lambeau Field
this reverse line movement here is so
interesting so it open three and a half
it got up to five now it's back down to
four keep an eye on that and also keep
an eye on that Packers pass rush against
the Seattle Seahawks and mister Russell
Wilson I like the under here but as
always a nice primetime game hang tight
wait because it's gonna get bad up Kelly
if you're like me the five-second rule
is sometimes a way of life and I'll let
the five-second rule extend to 15
seconds if the candy it's to living room
floor I know you can't do that because
you have three dogs and if they did all
the candy off the carpet you'd be at the
vet in like 90 minutes for sure so when
skittles fell from the sky
when Marshawn Lynch scored his first
touchdown of the season if I was on my
ground screw none of those taquitos
would go to waste and I'm a grown man
saying that beastmode the most popular
player in the NFL leads off our player
props offered by the Caesars Palace
sports book are you betting that
Marshawn Lynch will score touchdown I
get in go in Green Bay
against the 29th ranked defense so
you're mentioning that defense and I
mentioned that Packers pass rush which i
think is going to force the Seattle
Seahawks to have to go to the ground
here thus
the beach when you feed the beasts what
happens he's gonna score touchdown why
cuz surely at this point in time he
carols learned on the goal line feed
Marsh on a yes plus 145 Kelly the NFL's
leading rusher set a franchise record
182 yards on the ground last week in New
England talking about Derek Henry do you
see more value in the over ninety two
and a half rushing yards or the under
ninety two and a half against the Ravens
this one's been bad up all week and
rightfully so because what does the
public remember what they saw last
exactly what you said last week versus
the Patriots this one is now five yards
too high for me to even consider betting
the over and I'm also not dumb enough to
step in front of this freight train
I do lean towards the under here but
there's no way I'm getting to the window
with this problem the Baltimore Ravens
use the most pre snap motions in the NFL
and they're 23 year-old superstar
quarterback and future MVP has so many
ways to kill your defense the props
offered our passing yards over/under 205
and a half what do you think about this
one Kells you know this one's come down
kind of shocks me I didn't think that it
would I think Lamar Jackson's gonna have
a big game on the ground and in the air
I like the over okay let's go to the
ground for the next one rushing yards
over and under over or under excuse me
75 and a half I think a bookmakers did a
great job with this number I made him 75
rushing yards for this game but
situationally I can't bet this under
Lamar Jackson will break one at least in
this game for 20 or 30 yards and my bet
will be toast so I lean towards the over
here because it because of that
situation but just know that there's no
value really on one side or the other
and finally Willie score a rushing
touchdown Kelly yes - yes plus 150 no -
170 how do you think he's gonna play
bookmakers are baiting you here they
keep making that cost money more entire
school
take the bait why because he's not gonna
score one well I do think he has a big
game he's not getting to the end zone
all right here is a recap of my prop
bets for the divisional round Marshawn
Lynch will score a touchdown
Derrick Henry under 92 and a brushing
yards and Lamar Jackson to have himself
a game but not put one in the end zone
I'm here for all means
our Jackson geeking out defenders out of
there Khaleesi like those moves on
Saturday night we're here for your
questions because Kelly has great
answers these are the minds of the
public Big Jake when asked when
sprinkling on the money line how do you
determine good value I've noticed that
bunny lines can vary widely even when
the spread doesn't change yeah Jake
you're absolutely right a lot of people
don't realize but the money lines aren't
always correlated to the spread now when
I'm looking for those outright dogs I'm
shopping around for the best money line
but I don't take it into consideration
in terms of value against the spread so
if I like a six-point underdog I'm gonna
find the best correlated money line
because I think that team's gonna win
outright but I'm not gonna say well
because this is my plus 210 when it
should be plus 230 that means the dogs
gonna went out right I don't think
there's as much correlation there as
people like to buy into hockey Hoss
wonders would you hedge out of a Seattle
Super Bowl futures bet this person got
it at 25 to 1 that's a good number but
technically you should wait until next
week the hedge and as I mentioned this
is a tough game I'm not sure Seahawks
are gonna make it out of Lambeau alive
so depending on how much your initial
investment is you may look to head a
little bit here this week and hockey
leaves biceps just straight yoked wants
to know how quarterbacks making their
first career playoff star performed
historically against the spread well we
know experience matters in the
postseason quarterbacks making their
first career playoff start thirteen
thirty three and one against the spread
mm cabbie that is less than 30 percent
and we saw it against the Texans Josh
Allen had himself a monster three
quarters and couldn't get it done
speaking of quarters this man didn't
even make it out of the first quarter
this guy right here owes a lot to
Derrick Henry but he did get the win
especially on the road yes in New
England so credit to Ryan Tannehill and
then we have this week's quarterback
Jimmy Garoppolo is Jimmy gonna do well
in his first start well that's a great
transition into my best bet
[Music]
alright guys my best vest as I mentioned
12 5 and 1 on the season in the last
couple of weeks have been really rough
not this week
because Kurt cousins is not playing in
primetime I cannot wait for this game
it's gonna be awesome so we can occur
cousins who does he have on the
sidelines that's right coach Zimmer my
favorite coach why this man covers the
spread we talked about this weekend and
week out and you have to pick your spots
with this team 44 19 and 1 that's right
coach Zimmer versus non divisional teams
and Warren Sharpe touched on this a
little bit but home favorites to sweep
between six and a half and nine points
historically 2 and 11 against the spread
I'm rocking with down the coach tab a
big game that strong front 7 Adam
Thielen please come to play I like the
Vikings plus 7-inch don't forget to
sprinkle a little bit of that on the
money line let's recap all of my
divisional round sticks these are listed
in order of confidence on how many units
I'd recommend you bet on each I've got a
four unit plan the Vikings as my best
bet three in a play on the saddle Green
Bay under again guys hang tight wait for
that one because I do believe it's going
to be fed up and I also have two units
on the Texans and the Titans if you're
looking for more postseason action the
college football playoffs conclude
Monday night between Clemson and LSU and
Kelly in our social squad have been
facing off in a picks contest throughout
the bowl season where do you stand now
heading into the final game cavy really
do we have to talk about this the social
guys are beating me 23 to 22 I'm not
happy about that and granted I only
probably bent eight of these games in
real life but we had to pick every Dame
on the board they're currently in first
place but this one's gonna decide it all
because it's worth three points they
have LSU -6 I have Clemson plus 6 but of
course I flipped Clemson plus 6 I was
just upstairs in the green room
listening to hell the Talking Heads are
trying to give home-field advantage
Dallas yield it is in my understand the
game
in New Orleans but the game is not in
Baton Rouge it is not at Death Valley
yes it'll probably be 6535 claims in LSU
fans but people are buying into this
hike just a little too much for what the
LSU Tigers did against Oklahoma I wish
you luck cows thank you for joining us
on the be our bedding show it has been
presented by the Caesars Palace sports
club be sure to follow along at br
underscore betting to track all my picks
and catch the conclusion of our college
football bowl contests good luck on all
your bets and here's to a profitable
weekend
[Applause]
[Music]